will the country be post merkel
a change of direction barred from
blocking the m25 insulate britain
climate protesters turn their attention
to dover
and why the uk's mosques haven't just
issued a call to prayer today but also a
call for climate action
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions now germans will vote this
sunday in elections that will see angela
merkel's 16-year reign as chancellor
come to an end climate change has played
heavily in the election campaign at one
point the green party was even leading
the polls it's now slipped to third
place but the results could still see it
become part of a coalition government
so let's have a look at just how green
or otherwise germany is so the country
is europe's biggest emitter of carbon
dioxide and its energy mix is still
heavily reliant on fossil fuels in 2019
about 77 of germany's energy came from
fossil fuels that compares to just 22
percent of energy from renewables
just five percent of the country's
energy comes from nuclear compared to
about 36 percent in neighboring france
this is partly because since 1998
germany has been phasing out nuclear
energy which has always been unpopular
after the 2011 fukushima disaster it
immediately shut down eight of its 17
reactors and plans to shut all of its
plants by next year
in june germany adopted an amendment to
its climate law together with an 8
billion euro climate emergency program
following a constitutional court ruling
that its climate targets were too weak
and put future generations in danger but
even with the amendment germany's
scheduled 2038 coal phase-out is
incompatible with the 1.5 degree warming
limit of the paris agreement well our
europe correspondent adam parsons is in
munich this evening adam just how much
has climate featured in the campaigning
in the run-up to this weekend's
elections
it's a significant factor for about
20-25 of voters it is the number one
thing there's no doubt that it's playing
uh a big part in this election the
reason we're munich is just around the
corner from us uh we have a conference
center where the cdu that is angela
merkel's party uh have been holding one
of their last rallies i'm in lasher the
contender for them
is there along with all the great and
the good from the cdu but they are
trailing uh in the polls at the moment
going to these final days and climate is
one of the reasons the green party is
polling better that has done
in previous elections
picking up a bit on some of the anger
after those floods that we had uh just a
few months ago they have another pickup
they might expect but certainly for
younger voters particularly i think it's
important big protests across germany
today including in berlin
where the crowd was addressed by greta
tinberg here's what she told them
we must vote you must vote
but remember that voting only will not
be enough
we must keep going into the streets and
we must keep demanding our leaders to
take real climate action
uh of course gretenberg is swedish you
won't be voting on this but over 60
million people will now at the moment
the predictions are that yet again
germany will have a coalition
how that looks we simply don't know and
it takes potentially weeks maybe even
months to put that coalition together
the merkle rain could continue one
person told us today they thought it
might go up until christmas it will be
down to analina bearbot the leader of
the greens to play her cards correctly
one analyst telling me that actually he
thinks that she may have a stronger
position to force a climate agenda if
she's part of a coalition
rather than the chancellor
adam thank you
and we're going to be discussing whether
climate change is a key issue for german
voters on today's debate i'm going to be
joined by the economist vicki price and
professor of global change science at
ucl and the university of leeds simon
lewis
that's in a few minutes time
now after blocking sections of the m25
five times in the past fortnight
insulate britain protesters were banned
by the high court this week from
blocking the motorway and threatened
with prison by the transport secretary
grant shaps so today members of the
extinction rebellion offshoot changed
attack and headed for dover where 39
people were arrested after blocking the
entrance to the port skyzarzahed was
there
insulate britain have been protesting in
dover today around 40 protesters
blocking off access to the port of dover
the a2 and a third group blocking a part
of the a20 and not only have they
disrupted roads today but also channel
crossings now we saw similar tactics
being used as we have seen in their
previous protests hands being glued to
the road and two activists also mounted
a tanker it took nearly five hours to
get them off understandably there were
lots and lots of frustrated and angry
motorists on the road and the
government's also come back and said
that they are taking action against
these guerrilla tactics being used to
prevent them from happening in the
future now insulate britain are
demanding that the government does more
to make homes more energy efficient to
help tackle climate change they've
protested on the m25 five times the
government's been granted an injunction
against them for this they've also held
demonstrations on the m3 and m11 more
than 200 arrests made so far and it's
not stopping them they say they're not
scared of being arrested they're not
scared of government injunctions what
they are fearful of is climate change
now in some of today's other climate
news big businesses including bt thames
water and the co-op have called on the
government to phase out gas power by
2035. in a letter shared exclusively
with sky news the business told
ministers the time's right for the uk to
signal an end to the use of unabated
fossil fuels
sustainability told us it was all
important in the light of recent price
hikes
well we've seen the rising cost of
importing gas is pushing up prices for
both businesses and consumers and this
trend is set to continue so the best way
for us to guarantee energy security in
the uk
is by generating our own electricity
from clean sources and of course this
can play a massive role in tackling
climate change
half a million acres of the scottish
highlands are to be rewilded as part of
efforts to restore nature the 30-year
project will increase connected habitats
and species diversity across the africa
highlands the scenario between the west
coast of scotland and loch ness plans
include planting trees enhancing river
corridors restoring peat bogs and
creating nature friendly farming
practices
homeowners affected by flooding are
spending an average of 5
250 pounds each year to protect and
repair their homes according to research
from the climate coalition homeowners
living on flood plains are also paying
more for contents insurance the
environment agency estimates that 5.2
million properties in the uk are
currently at risk of flooding and
climate change could cause that number
to double in the next 50 years
now hundreds of mosques across the uk
didn't just issue a call for prayer
today they also used their friday
sermons to call for action on climate
change the message was organized by the
muslim charities forum as part of the
big green week
chowdhury has this report
zeki ismail is a farm shop owner who
doesn't like to give his customers much
choice
chicken duck turkey it doesn't matter
what you go for here you have to choose
ethical when we're looking at thai it's
something that's pure it's natural
it's ethical
it's it's a natural way of raising
livestock
and it's a clean and
it's a it's a product that's clean and
it's not just with meat also with fruit
and vegetables
and anything else that we would consume
or anything else that we would tend to
do in our lives
the search for ethical farming led zeki
to this farm in seven oaks where animals
are grass-fed
muslims eat above average quantities of
meat which explains why the halal market
is one of the fastest growing in the
uk's meat industry
but many focus only on halal forgetting
that ethical or tayib is just as
important a more islamic diet muslim
communities could have a big impact on
how we tackle climate change on british
farms
eat those foods that are halal and that
are also pure for you as well
today at friday prayers across the
country a reminder that fussy eaters
will go to heaven
300 mosques are putting climate change
at the heart of their sermons and it's
not just about making better dietary
choices but also things like switching
to renewable energy and reducing how
much we consume
the imam is using early islamic
traditions to try and win over his
audience
at aleman center in bromley imam
abdullah explains why addressing climate
change is central to islam islamically
you know we believe that god created the
universe god created the earth and he
has placed us in this planet on this
earth as custodians or caretakers
meaning that as humankind we have to
take care of ourselves take care of
other humankind also take care of the
plant life take care of the animals and
the
environment
muslims are being reminded to make more
ethical more islamic choices
and the message is clear
protect the world you live in and that
could be what gets you to heaven once
you've left
sadia chowdhury sky news
do stay with us because coming up after
the break
i'm going to be joined by the economist
vicki price and professor of global
change science science lewis and we're
going to be discussing if germany is a
climate change leader and whether it's
realistic for the uk to phase out gas
power by 2035
[Music]
i am going part of the amazon biome to
guyana
and i'm crossing the kanuki mountains
now the kanuki mountains are a protected
area in guyana it's very very special
and they're full of a lot of high jungle
mountains um and it's a long way i'm
sort of i'm basically tracking the
higher the length the width of guyana
the jungle expeditions it's so so dense
so we can expect to sometimes only be
moving um a whole day one kilometer
maybe in a day
uh it's gonna be hard it's gonna be uh
uncharted unknown the maps about the
only maps i have really are back from
the 70s and they were done um by someone
in a plane going past the camera so
they're not not that reliable um but
it's just going to be a case of getting
on the ground and seeing what happens
main reason for doing this expedition is
to both celebrate and make people aware
of what can be achieved when we protect
our wild places it's very very amazing
that guyana have been protected these
canoe mountains and they're so by full
of biodiversity as a result of it um so
that's the first thing the other thing
um i want to do with this exhibition is
to both inspire and empower hopefully
more people to just get out there and um
go go for it go through and achieve
achieve their dreams and see their
potential because that's definitely what
this is about for me i crossed these
mountains this mountain range from south
to north last year a much shorter
journey but it gave me a taste of what's
to come and during that journey
uh it's right in the middle in the
middle of the the worst point where any
danger um
could could show itself came and we got
surrounded by bushmaster snakes and
jaguars and it sounds like something
from a horror film um but i'm very aware
that this this is a big these are big
risks
uh other risks that are yeah
river crossings um deadfall which is
trees falling and of course like
infections and heat exhaustion
but it's all managed risk it's all
things that i've thought about and
trained for and myself and my great team
are ready for it i'm traveling with four
awesome amerindians who all of whom i
know from previous expeditions in the
jungles have hand-picked them um they're
just their skills and their tribal
skills they're from different tribes
around the area
are just just going to be so so useful
and the dynamic that we have is very
very special
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself
which houses frogs snakes crabs turtles
birds so many different life forms
human beings directly depend on
underground water source so a lake or a
pond is necessary to replenish these
groundwater resources
did you know that driving us to school
creates extra toxic air at drop-off and
pick-up times
the weather stays fairly quiet and warm
over the weekend we could see daytime
highs up to around 24 even 25 degrees
celsius there's a good deal of dry
weather around too but also large
amounts of cloud at times early mist and
fog in the south and later on we'll see
some
more persistent rain working its way
towards the northwest although it'll be
sunday before it comes through
so a largely fine day top temperatures
again around 24 even 25 degrees celsius
fairly breezy with strong winds in the
north so air pollution levels will be
low
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show here on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day with the
economist vicki price and simon lewis
professor of global change science at
ucl and the university of leeds there
they are and we've been looking ahead of
sunday's german election that we'll see
the end of angela merkel's 16 years in
power at the country's green credentials
the climate has featured heavily in the
election campaign but is germany as
green as it would like to think simon
and vicky thank you so much for joining
us um simon let's start with you just
how green is germany
uh germany's not that green in that
about a quarter of its electricity is
coming from coal-fired power stations
very polluting and it's coming from the
worst kind of coal lignite
and it doesn't have a phase out until
2038
and to put that in context
uh xi jinping the chinese leader
announced at the un
that it would phase out
all overseas financing of coal-fired
power stations and struck out 47
coal-fired power stations with that one
sentence
and that's about the same carbon
emission stopped as germany's emitting
with its coal-fired power stations today
and on cars it doesn't have any phase
out date
for phase it for ending the sale of new
petrol and diesel cars
and
without that
and with the coal
uh the the supreme court in uh in
germany
uh said that germany's climate policies
were
unconstitutional because young people
wouldn't have a good life in the future
because these policies were not
committed that were not
consistent with
the paris agreement
interesting isn't it um a recent poll
found that 65 of germans are in favor of
stricter measures to fight climate
change vicky what do you think it's
interesting that the the greens are in
third place you'd think
with that sort of public support they'd
be right up there in first wouldn't you
you would indeed but of course we must
remember that uh germany is a major
manufacturing country
uh has a much larger percentage of
manufacturing is gdp than is the case in
the uk so phasing out all that there's
lots of energy-intensive sectors there
which we find it difficult to move to
uh you know
using
cleaner energy
uh because basically not much cleaner
energy is necessarily supplied and what
is going on right now of course is that
germany is relying heavily on gas that
comes out of russia it has said it's
going to stop any new nuclear and of
course that's been phased out so it's
limited in terms of what you can
actually do but i think on the positive
side we need to bear in mind that it's
very much part of the bush right now uh
that the eu is making in terms of uh
clean uh green bonds
raising money that can be spent in more
energy efficient
uh production and of course it's also
moving way ahead of other countries in
battery production so there is still a
lot that is happening the question is
how fast can they move to meet where the
population was but as you say
interestingly the greens are not doing
uh as well as perhaps you would have
expected we suggest to me that uh the
germans still value quite a lot of what
is being produced right now by the by
the industry there that existed present
um simon let's go back to this court
ruling that you mentioned april 2021 a
court ruled that germany's climate
change laws are insufficient again it
looks like all the right noises are
being made angela merkel herself was a
supporter of climate protection measures
do you think we are going to see a
change after these elections that
change will actually take place and it
won't just be talk
well i think it's it's uh it's going to
be difficult to say and that's because
the german
electoral system is is different from
the uk and they will have a coalition
um but if it's a coalition between some
of the left parties and the green party
then that probably gives the greatest
chance of really shifting policies
towards a much greener agenda whether
that's green homes
electric vehicles and getting uh their
um electricity supply onto renewables as
fast as possible
okay well let's um let's leave the
germans well obviously we found out this
weekend how that election will play out
because we've also heard today that big
uk businesses including bt thames water
the co-op and nestle have called on the
government to phase out gas power by
2035 that's just 14 years away so is it
achievable um vicky what do you think 40
of the uk's electricity
generation comes from gas plants do you
think we can phase it out by 2035
i think it's going to be rather
difficult the reason why they're calling
for it of course uh is because of the
increase they're adjusting in gas prices
there is a belief that we don't have
enough security to supply and therefore
we need to move into something else now
the question is are they asking for this
because it's clean or are they asking
for this because they really want to
make sure that whatever power there is
comes easily to the very sectors that
need it and you know it could be a
combination of the two which
would be interesting but it costs a lot
to move from where we are now in terms
of using different type of fuel if you
like in those very heavy energy
intensive sectors like for example
steels and chemicals and cement where
the costs are
very very great in terms of moving into
something else and they use huge amount
of heat for the process of production
that they've got at present so it is
going to be difficult it will require
a lot more investment than what we've
got planned at present
um so what do you think given what we're
seeing at the moment um not having to
rely on gas imports it sounds like it
would be an excellent thing
uh yes it would be and uh i don't think
it's that much of a surprise that these
household names have called for it
because
the government's statutory body on uh
advising and among climate change the
committee on climate change actually
says that unabated gas should be over by
2035.
so it's actually consistent with what
the messages that the government is
getting and what we are seeing
here is is a kind of a difference
between what the
most cost effective and the least
disruptive
way forward that the committee on
climate changes are laying out and the
policies that have been put in place and
not being put in place in a timely
manner to get us there and
i think on fossil fuels
there was a great report out last week
from oxford university that showed that
for fossil fuels
that are the costs that are adjusted for
inflation they have not got any cheaper
over the last
140 years
whereas renewables have been decreasing
in price incredibly rapidly they are 2
000 times
cheaper today than they were
50 years ago so it makes sense to get
onto renewables
and off fossil fuels and vicky is
correct in that there are some
industrial processes that require uh
huge amounts of heat but carbon-free
production of steel has already started
in sweden and the uk needs to get at the
beginning of the head of that curve and
move to those green industries to get
those green jobs and a transition away
from these dirty heavy industries
towards green industries but vicky it
does all come down to money doesn't it
getting there the lesser even says the
move would require a significantly
greater level of investment in
renewables that has been possible to
date and that's 14 billion pounds a year
who's gonna foot that bill
well that's a very good point i think
what the government needs to do right
now
is to share the risk if you like with
the private sector there is a lot of
money around that can be invested in
green technology as we've seen you know
those that people are buying up uh
companies like there's no tomorrow and
they are prepared to support list of
governments who are trying to raise
money so there is a lot of liquidity
around that can be used
properly to support a cleaner economy
though the problem is that the risks
involved with technology are still very
great so governments i'm afraid have to
step in like they're doing in the eu i
think we need to do that in the uk as
well and share that risk and give a sort
of guarantee to whoever may want to go
down that investment rate but without
that i think there would be a lot of
reluctance to engage in something which
may just lead to no results at all for
individual investors
okay vicky price simon lewis thank you
so much it's been fantastic talking to
you have a great weekend thank you
that's everything from us for this week
but do stay tuned because coming up next
on sky news tonight ministers hold
crisis talks on how the national
shortage of lorry drivers can be
resolved as cues